parano le tuer ses poursuivants pense
que des gens sont cachés dans sentir
dans cette voiture aucune intervention
n'est banal comme le prouvent ces
informations concernant une dame en
psychose
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le quotidien des
intervenants de l'urgence sociale que la
division de la police de laval
prévisible c'est de l'inconnu
sur place les patrouilleurs attendent
déjà l'équipe d'urgence sociale pour
évaluer le risque comme la dame s'est
réfugié dans son logement
les deux intervenantes demande aux
policiers d'entrée en premier forme et
en santé mentale
les deux travailleuses sociales entament
le dialogue après un certain temps elles
parviennent à désamorcer la situation
la présence des policiers dérange la
dame urgence sociale jugent que les
policiers peuvent quitter les lieux
vous allez
l'agente erika landry reprend le volant
de son auto patrouille
elle est contente qu urgent social ait
pu prendre le relais on n'est pas un
intervenant social on est policier
on essaie d'aider le plus possible mais
il ya des choses qu'on comprend pas qui
est des choses compte qu'on peut pas
pousser plus loin dans nos interventions
la question de la maladie mentale est
devenu de plus en plus fréquentes dans
le travail des patrouilleurs au début de
ma carrière on avait des appels en santé
mentale on en avait mais un système
mais le de plus en plus que les années
avancent c'est notre quotidien et que ça
peut être quelqu'un qui est dans le
besoin comme ça peut être quelqu'un qui
a une carrière qu'on n'aurait jamais
pensé mais ça se passe chez lui ce
qu'ils font appel à nous ça touche
toutes les couches de la société
en 2006 la police de laval fait appel à
sa division d'urgence sociale environ
200 fois par année quinze ans plus tard
c'est plus de 1200 x annuellement et on
parle de 400 % d'augmentation
martin métivier et chef de cette
division il dirige une dizaine de
travailleuses sociales qui font face à
toutes sortes de situations
cette année la police de laval va
équiper urgence sociale de radio
d'autopatrouilles pour écouter en temps
réel les appels ou de faim alors votre
saison de radio police et en plus on va
être sur les terminaux véhiculaires fait
qu'on va voir en temps réel les appels
qui sont en train de rentrer l'urgence
sociale pourra donc décidé de se
déplacer sans attendre la demande des
policiers
il va aussi envoyer
d'emblée des agents d'urgence sociale
qui vont mener nouveaux ronds sont des
interventions qu'on va avoir une
intervention pourrait être prise directe
dans le cas de la dame en détresse
elle a accepté de retourner
volontairement à l'est le psychiatrique
de la cité de la santé
ici pascal robidas radio canada à laval